Hello everyone, this is Dogen. In today's video,
as the title says, I
would like to talk about discrimination, which has been a hot topic among Japanese language learners lately. To be honest, I
didn't want to touch on this topic, but
Dogen-san's...  There
were a lot of people who wanted to hear their opinions, so I'll just say what I think. I
can't believe that even in this day and age I still have to say things like this.
First of all, let me explain the situation for you. To
put it simply, there
were people who were arguing that we should only use hiragana from the beginning, or that we should just use romaji for a while.
Both sides had their own opinions.  I
didn't try to do anything about it, so this discussion
escalated, and
from the middle of it, it
turned into an insult tournament, and eventually I was told that I should
n't have anything to do with people who say this, and I have to block them.This is basically bullying, or rather, it's
normal.
Can you believe that? That's
not the point here either.
What do you mean about how to
write ``tu'' instead of ``TSU''
? That's right. Let's block those people.